When you think of Easter eggs in popular culture,
you tend to think of them being included in
movies - and rightfully so, as movies are
full of fun references and nods these days
- but television shows are also starting to
get in on the act.
You can often find sneaky inclusions - or
even explicit mentions - of other franchises
in television series.
As one of the most popular movie franchises
of all time - and an important part of pop
culture history - Star Wars is one of the
most often referenced franchises in fiction.
Here, we'll list ten examples in which that's
been the case on the small screen.
So please, watch our video, subscribe to our
channel, and keep checking ScreenRant for
more great videos in the same mould as this
one.
Here are ten popular TV shows that referenced
Star Wars.
Family Guy
How could we make a video about TV shows that
referenced Star Wars without mentioning Seth
MacFarlane's brilliant Family Guy?
As well as multiple references in the regular
shows, it also goes without saying that the
animated series about the Griffin family and
their friends and associates has full-on parodied
Star Wars on more than one occasion in the
form of Laugh It Up, Fuzzball: The Family
Guy Trilogy.
The first of the trilogy was 2007's Blue Harvest,
which was followed by 2009's Something, Something,
Something, Dark Side and 2010's It's a Trap!
It's a retelling of the original Star Wars
trilogy with Family Guy characters as Star
Wars characters, such as Peter Griffin as
Han Solo, Stewie Griffin as Darth Vader, Brian
Griffin as Chewbacca and Chris Griffin as
Luke Skywalker.
If you haven't seen the trilogy already, watch
it!
It's superb.
American Dad
Predictably, given that it's also a Seth MacFarlane
show and he's clearly a fan of the franchise,
American Dad has also made a number of references
to Star Wars over the years.
While it hasn't explicitly parodied the franchise
like Family Guy has, it's certainly been mentioned
in the show a lot.
Examples include Steve Smith's ongoing interest
in the franchise, Stan Smith confusing Star
Wars with Star Trek, Stan meeting the internet
phenomenon known as Star Wars kid at a convention
that also included characters dressed as Stormtroopers
and Ewoks, and Steve having two assistants
dressed like Princess Leia in her slave girl
outfit.
Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
The Phase 2 movies of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe all had a recurring Easter egg that
was a nod to the Star Wars franchise - characters
would lose a hand or arm, just like Luke Skywalker
did in 1980's The Empire Strikes Back.
The likes of Aldrich Killian in Iron Man 3
and Ulysses Klaue in Avengers: Age of Ultron
are examples of that.
But it also extended to the MCU's television
spin-off, Agents of S.H.I.E.L.D.
Agent Phil Coulson asked Mack to amputate
his lower arm to prevent further petrification
caused by a Terrigen Crystal in the season
two finale S.O.S. and he now has a prosthetic
hand - which is also like Luke Skywalker.
Doctor Who
Doctor Who is among the most likely television
shows to reference Star Wars, given the space-settings
in each franchise, so it's no surprise that
there was a cool reference in one episode
of the show.
It came in Face the Raven - the tenth episode
of the ninth series of the show's modern run
- and it came in the form an odd looking box
in the background.
There was a bizarre language written on the
box, which actually turned out to be Aurebesh,
the standard language in the Star Wars universe.
Even more interestingly, fans of Star Wars
have deciphered it - and it actually says
"DeLorean", which means it doubles-up as a
Back to the Future Easter egg too!
The Simpsons
We now come to another classic animated series
in the form of The Simpsons.
Matt Groening must also be a big fan of the
Star Wars franchise, as The Simpsons is absolutely
teaming with references to it - so let's get
to a few of them without further ado.
The first ever Treehouse of Horror episode
saw Lisa snooping around Kang and Kodos' ship.
The ship itself and the and music playing
at the time were very reminiscent of the halls
of the Death Star and Luke Skywalker's theme
from the first Star Wars movie.
In the episode Lisa the Beauty Queen, Lisa
tried a few different hairstyles - one of
which was Princess Leia's.
In the episode Burns, Baby Burns, Darth Vader's
mask could be seen in Springfield's costume
shop.
And in The Last Temptation of Krust, the "Java
the Hut" coffeehouse was an obvious reference
to Jabba the Hutt.
Buffy the Vampire Slayer
Joss Whedon's classic television show Buffy
the Vampire Slayer had a lot of references
to Star Wars - with Nicholas Brendon's Xander
Harris and the evil Trio in particular being
huge fans of the franchise, as they quoted
and referred to it on many occasions - but
they weren't the only characters to do so.
Faith, Ben and a number of other characters
made references to the franchise, while Spike
even referred to Angel as "his Yoda" in the
episode School Hard.
It should also be noted that the spin-off
show, Angel, had a number of Star Wars references,
such as Charles Gunn referring to Angelus
as "Darth Vampire" in the episode Calvary.
The Buffy the Vampire Slayer theme tune was
also notably performed by the band "Nerf Herder",
who were named after Princess Leia's comment
to Han Solo in The Empire Strikes Back.
Firefly
Joss Whedon must have a thing for Star Wars,
because Buffy the Vampire Slayer and Angel
weren't the only shows of his to reference
the epic sci-fi franchise - the short-lived
Firefly series did too.
In the pilot episode, when Inara is docking
the shuttle, an Imperial shuttle from Star
Wars flies over head.
Also, in the episode Shindig, just as the
camera pans down to the crew in the streets,
you can see the Star Wars ship known as the
Starlight Intruder.
This ship isn't from the Star Wars movies,
but it is from the Dark Horse Comics Star
Wars metaseries from the 1990s entitled Dark
Empire.
The Big Bang Theory
The Big Bang Theory's four main characters
- Leonard Hofstadter, Sheldon Cooper, Howard
Wolowitz and Rajesh Koothrappali - are all
huge fans of all things sci-fi, and that undoubtedly
includes Star Wars, so we could be on all
day with the number of Star Wars references
in the show.
With that in mind, we're only going to mention
the best one.
It happened after Sheldon's childhood hero,
Bob Newhart's Arthur Jeffries who played kids'
TV character Professor Proton, had sadly passed
away.
Professor Proton's ghost returns as a Jedi,
dressed in full Jedi garb, to give Sheldon
some advice in The Opening Night Excitation
episode (the one in which Sheldon wants to
watch The Force Awakens, incidentally).
South Park
Trey Parker and Matt Stone, like previous
show creators in this video, are quite obviously
huge Star Wars fans, because their brilliant
animated series South Park contains countless
references to the franchise.
Here are just a few examples...
The character of George Lucas appears on more
than one occasion in the show - in the episodes
Free Hat and The China Probrem, for example.
Chef is turned into a cyborg called Darth
Chef in The Return of Chef.
Luke Skywalker, is seen as a member of the
Council of Nine in Imaginationland, Episode
II.
And Stormtroopers are seen murdering The Lollipop
King in Imaginationland, Episode III.
The Walking Dead
The Walking Dead is, arguably, the most popular
television show on the small screen right
now, so it's only fitting that it should reference
one of the most most popular movie franchises
of all time in Star Wars - and it has.
That being said, The Walking Dead is unique
on this list, in the sense that the references
don't come from in the show itself.
One of them was on Twitter, when the show's
official account tweeted a mashup poster of
the two franchises and prompted fans to reply
with similar crossovers.
Additionally, on Red Nose Day in 2016, NBC
aired a sketch that saw The Walking Dead cast
spoofing the classic Star Wars Christmas special
- a sketch that even featured two actors playing
Han Solo!
Thanks for watching our video about ten popular
TV shows that referenced Star Wars.
Can you think of any other TV shows with Star
Wars references in them?
Have your say in the comments section below
and be sure to subscribe to our channel for
more great videos like this one.